Hey guys, Pete here.
This will be my Game of Thrones Season 8 episode
6 trailer breakdown.
I wasn't expecting them to give away much
in the trailer, and unfortunately I was right.
Still, we have some things to talk about in
this, and it is the final trailer for the
last episode of Game of Thrones ever.
So, it's not like I was going to take the
day off after doing this for years.
The first thing that stood out to me is that
whole trailer appears to be tied together
and related to a short period of time.
Since we know episode 6 is another 80 minute
long episode this means that we're only looking
at a part of the series finale that we imagined
was inevitable anyway the time after the fighting
ends and Daenerys looks at what her victory
cost.
I wondered as I looked at the last scene if
she's spoken to any of the people we see in
this trailer.
I thought Arya returning was the most surprising
thing, and we'll talk about that after we
get through the images.
Let's break it down scene by scene, all 9
of them, and then talk about where things
are headed.
The episode 6 trailer opens with a shot of
Davos and Jon walking through the ruins of
King's Landing.
We see fire burning inside a window behind
them, and a body on the ground in the front
of the frame.
What stands out here is that there is a skeleton
on the left of the shot that looks like a
child to me.
It's pretty gruesome.
Even though we saw all that stuff go down
in episode 5 it's still pretty gruesome to
see the way that this small skeleton looks
framing that window there.
There isn't any voiceover in this trailer
so we're left to wonder what these two characters
might be thinking as they walk through the
destruction.
The next shot shows Tyrion walking alone doing
the same thing Jon and Davos probably doing.
Taking in the reality of the destruction.
We see blood smeared on the walls of the city
and fires still burning on the streets.
We have to imagine that Tyrion is in a tough
position here after seeing how his plan to
stop the destruction himself didn't exactly
work out.
We had the ominous warning from Daenerys that
the next time Tyrion failed her would be the
last time.
And, I have to imagine this is going through
his head as he's walking towards the center
of town.
After that we see what's left of the Red Keep.
This doesn't reveal much since we witnessed
Daenerys attacking it in episode 5.
Since it follows the shot of Tyrion this could
be from his perspective, and he would have
to be thinking about Cersei and Jaime.
At this point he might still think its possible
that Jaime was able to reach Cersei and get
her out of King's Landing in time.
I doubt by this time that Tyrion knows what
happened to them.
Arya arrives next.
We see the remaining Dothraki in front of
her, and she's probably going where we see
her next.
If you're keeping track Tyrion and Arya are
the only two characters that we see more than
once in this trailer and they are both moving
through the city alone.
The next shot is of Arya again, and she's
standing behind the Unsullied.
Knowing what she lived through in episode
5 we can have a pretty good guess what's going
through her mind here.
She is probably looking at Daenerys here,
and she looks absolutely vengeful as she is
processing the emotions that are running through
her.
Then we see what's left of the Unsullied standing
looks like what's left of King's Landing.
They've followed their Queen a long way to
get to this place, and they should be coming
out of the battle in pretty good shape.
All things considered it was a one-sided battle
so they shouldn't have taken too many casualties
during that.
In the second shot we see of Tyrion he looks
deeply troubled.
We get a good idea of how the ashes are covering
everything in this shot.
This reminds us of a couple things from past
seasons.
In season 2 episode 8 Tyrion and Cersei are
talking about Joffrey fighting in the battle
of Blackwater.
Cersei tells Tyrion that she has his whore
as a hostage to make sure nothing happens
to Joffrey in that battle.
After she presents Ros to him he tells her,
"I will hurt you for this.
I don't know how yet, but give me time.
A day will come when you think yourself safe
and happy and suddenly your joy will turn
to ashes in your mouth.
And, you'll know the debt is paid."
So, even though in the end he tried to save
her and her unborn child he ended up paying
off what he told her in season 2.
In season 7 we heard of ashes again when Tyrion
tells Daenerys, "Conquering Westeros would
be easy for you, but you're not here to be
Queen of the Ashes."
Daenerys itself echoes that later on when
she's talking to her allies about attacking
King's Landing by saying, "I'm not here to
be the Queen of Ashes."
This of course leads into one of Lady Ollena
giving one of her famous speeches.
Saying, "He's a clever man, your hand.
I've known many clever men.
I've outlived them all, you know why?
I ignored them.
The Lords of Westeros are sheep.
Are you a sheep?
No, you're a dragon.
Be a dragon."
In retrospect I'm not sure this is what the
Queen of Thorns had in mind, but there definitely
was some dragon going on in King's Landing
in episode 5.
There is a quick look at the Dothraki cheering,
raising their weapons in the air.
They look victorious.
They look happy with their victory.
Then we see the closing shot of the trailer
as Daenerys walks out to address the assembled
soldiers.
It's pretty clear that King's Landing is destroyed
here, and her troops at least seem to be satisfied
with what went down.
As we saw in episode 5 she decided to be a
dragon, and so the Queen of Ashes it is.
It's a very powerful image this last image,
and it really drives home the uncertainty
of how everything is going to go past this
scene.
It's also clear that the other main characters
who followed Dany to this point are conflicted
about what just happened, and that's about
as far as they're going to go, and that's
about it for what they're going to give away
to us in this trailer.
So, we have some scenes that look like they
take place directly after the battle.
We can't tell how much time has passed, I
mean there are fires still burning out at
this point, but it's hard to imagine that
too much of the story will unfold before this
scene we have of Daenerys looking out over
the troops.
Jon and Davos will most likely be reckoning
with what they just went through and thinking
about how to proceed.
Beyond that we can only speculate on where
the rest of the episode might go.
I'll wait until later this week to see if
they release any other pictures before I get
into all of that.
The ashes in the trailer do make a good impression.
Beyond the callbacks I mentioned above it
reminds me of the long running debate about
the visions from earlier seasons.
In Daenerys' House of the Undying vision,
and later in Bran's weirwood vision we saw
the destroyed throne room.
Ever since then people have debated over whether
it was ash or snow falling from the sky, and
I guess now we do know.
Makes you wonder what the throne room will
actually look like we see Dany entering it
in episode 6.
I mentioned being surprised about Arya's return.
At the end of episode 5 I thought we might
be witnessing her riding away for good after
her conversation with the Hound.
The fact that she returned makes you wonder
what part she'll play in the aftermath.
Obviously we followed her harrowing journey
through the destruction so we know what she
saw.
But, we also saw her change her mind about
killing Cersei.
My guess is that a bunch of fans now will
jump on the idea that she's going to kill
Daenerys, and that would make some sense.
There's the whole "green eyes" thing that
people keep bringing up in my comments [laughing].
But, I do wonder since it seems odd to have
her change her course in episode 5 only to
re-up on being a killer in episode 6.
I'm really not sure.
Let me know what you guys think as far as
what part she'll play in the comments of this
video.
If she's there as things are going down then
I have to expect she's going to play a part
in whatever comes next.
So, being a main character, being involved,
it seems pretty important.
In this trailer we don't see anyone from the
story who wasn't in King's Landing for the
battle.
Episode 6 being the final episode of the entire
series means that we're definitely going to
be travelling north to Winterfell, or the
players that are there will be coming to King's
Landing.
Daenerys framing her betrayal as Jon betraying
her by telling Sansa was one of the things
that really stood out to me in the last episode.
While it seemed like there was a pretty good
chance Varys wouldn't make it out of the episode
alive, I was definitely surprised when Dany
shifted the blame for the betrayal from him
to Jon and Sansa.
She gave Jon a chance to come back to her
and in that process called out Sansa for what
she'd done.
So, there's absolutely a conflict brewing
between these two characters.
Besides Dany, Tyrion is certainly the character
in the toughest spot in the episode 6 trailer.
As viewers we can understand what he did by
freeing Jaime, but based on the way things
played out we know that it's going to come
back up.
I think it would be foolish to try to suppose
what's actually going through the Queen's
mind at this point.
I went over the path that she traveled to
reach this destination in my video yesterday,
but we're in the dark as far depth she's sunk
to at this time.
This makes Tyrion's outcome uncertain.
On the one hand he could explain away the
fact that he freed Jaime based on wanting
to get Cersei to surrender, and he is essentially
the only adviser she has left.
On the other hand what are the chances that
Daenerys will be keen to see this in any other
way than a betrayal?
That's about all there is to say about this
trailer.
We still have 80 minutes of story left to
tell so there's a lot that can happen.
Let me know in the comments what you guys
think about how they're going to wrap things
up.
Please like the video if you enjoyed it, please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't already.
We're getting ready to watch the final episode
of the series and I look forward to doing
that with you.
Thanks for watching, I will talk to you soon.